if you spend any time driving around
America recently you may have noticed
that an awful lot of the country seems
to have shriveled up and died take a
trip on route 2 in Maine sometime and
count the boarded up paper mills and
abandoned houses you see we're headed
down Route 23 in Michigan or Ohio and
consider the empty factories ringed with
barbed wire you'll see a lot of them
outside the coastal cities scenes like
this are everywhere this is your country
now shuttered car dealerships next to
defunct restaurants across street from
thrift stores and methadone clinics
that's America community after community
desiccated empty husks with nothing left
huge swaths the United States look like
that now so what happened well a lot of
things happen some of them are
complicated and hard to change but one
of the big factors in the slow-moving
disaster is the utter transformation of
the way our leaders think about the
American economy during the last Gilded
Age 125 years ago America's ruling class
may have been ostentatiously rich and
they were go to Newport Rhode Island for
proof if you like but it was still a
recognizably American class tycoons
accumulated fortunes but they also felt
some obligation to the country around
them steel kite tycoon Andrew Carnegie
famously built stone libraries around
the country for the edification of
people beneath him john d rockefeller
and many others so-called robber barons
set aside huge portions of their wealth
and in some cases their property to make
this country better
Yellowstone Acadia National Park etc
maybe most significantly in January of
1914 Henry Ford more than doubled the
prevailing factory wage - with then
remarkable $5 for an eight-hour day Ford
didn't have to do that but his company
was succeeding any thought he should
some historians trace the creation of
the American middle-class to that
decision either way it is nearly
impossible to imagine a big company
doing anything like that today attitudes
are just too different your average
finance mogul looks at workers merely as
cost to be reduced or eliminated
entirely private equity isn't building a
lot of public libraries these days
instead the model is ruthless economic
efficiency by a distressed company out
sorts the jobs liquidate the valuable
sets fire middle-management and once the
smoke has cleared dump what remains to
the highest bidder often in Asia it's
happened around the country it has made
a small number of people phenomenally
rich one of them is a new york-based
hedge fund manager called Paul singer
according to forbes has amassed a
personal fortune of more than three
billion dollars that was singer made
that money we've made a lot of it by
purchasing sovereign debt from
financially distressed countries
countries that were in trouble usually
at a massive discount once the country's
economy regains some stability singer
would bombard its government with
lawsuits from a massive public relations
campaign originating here in Washington
sometimes until he made his money back
with interest the practice is called
vulture capitalism feeding off the
carcass of a dying nation in some ways
it's not so different from what singer
and his firm Elliott management have
done in this country and to this country
over the past couple of decades Elliott
management has been billions by buying
large stakes in American companies than
firing workers driving up short-term
share prices and in some cases taking
government bailouts insult to injury
Bloomberg News once described singer as
quote the world's most feared investor
and that tells you a lot no one's even
pretending Paul singers tactics are good
for anyone but Paul singer and his fund
consider the case of Delphi the
automotive parts supplier during the
last financial crisis a consortium of
hedge funds including singers Elliott
Management purchased Delphi with singer
and the other funds at the helm the
company took billions of dollars in
government bailouts paid for by you
Obama's autos are compared those tactics
to extortion but they continued anyway
once they had the bailout money the
funds moved most of Delphi jobs overseas
and then either cut retiree pensions
entirely or shifted the cost to
taxpayers with later financial
commitments at home and sheep factories
abroad Delphi stock soared according to
investigative reporter Greg Palast of
the 29 Delphi plants and operation when
the hedge fund started buying Delphi his
debt only four we're still operating in
the United States by 2012 that means
tens of thousands have unionized and
white-collar workers lost their jobs
Paul singer's hedge fund cashed out for
more than a billion dollars see how that
works
well some countries including the United
Kingdom have banned this kind of
behavior it bears no resemblance
whatsoever to the capitalism we were
promised in school
it creates nothing it destroys entire
cities
it couldn't be uglier or more
destructive so why is this so allowed in
the United States
the short answer because people like
Paul singer have tremendous influence
over our political process singer
himself was the second largest donor to
the Republican Party in 2016
he's given millions to a super PAC that
supports Republican senators you may
never have heard of Paul singer which
tells you a lot in itself but in
Washington he is rock star famous and
that may be why he's almost certainly
paying a lower effective tax rate than
your average fireman just in case you're
still wondering if our system is rigged
oh yeah it is tonight we want to tell
you a little more about how Paul singer
does business the story begins in a
small town called Sidney Nebraska
population 6282
two hours outside Denver's Aiden Sidney
is the longtime home of the sporting
goods retailer Cabela's which sells
fishing and hunting gear in October of
2015
singer's hedge fund disclosed an 11
percent stake in Cabela's and said about
pushing the board to sell the company
Cabela's management apparently fearing a
long and costly fight with singer and
now it would look for a buyer now at the
time Cabela's was a relatively healthy
company it was posting nearly two
billion dollars a year in gross profits
four billion dollars in revenue there
didn't seem to be any immediate need to
sell but Cabela's sold anyway after
being pushed so one year after singer
entered the equation Bass Pro Shops
announced the purchase of Cabela's the
company's stock price surged within a
week literally a week Paul singer cashed
out he bought the stock for $38 a share
he sold it for 63 dollars a share his
hedge fund made at least 90 million
dollars up front and likely more over
time but in Sidney Nebraska it was a
very different story the residents of
Sidney did not get rich no just the
opposite their community was devastated
destroyed the town lost nearly 2,000
jobs a heartbreakingly familiar cascade
began people laughed
values collapsed and then people
couldn't leave they were trapped there
one of the last thriving small towns in
this country went under we recently sent
two producers to Sydney Nebraska to
survey the wreckage there and to
consider what happened our producers
talked to more than a dozen former
Cabela's employees almost all of them
refused to speak to us on camera fearful
of legal retribution from the famously
vicious Paul singer but off-camera they
told us their story
here it is Sydney is it's a great place
to be this is Sydney Nebraska a small
town two hours outside of Denver for
decades according to stone employer our
model forever was small-town values
big-time opportunities but that motto
was turned on its head when Elliott
Management Corporation that's a new
york-based hedge fund managed by
billionaire Paul singer took an
ownership stake in Cabela's when we got
the news this company is coming in from
New York City and buying a huge stake in
Cabela's that shakes things up at the
time Cabela's was making more than a
billion dollars a year but Paul singer's
firm sensed it could make a quick buck
by driving up the stock price by forcing
a merger
once thriving town in Sydney lost
everything that's how a long time
Cabela's employee reacted to news that
she was losing her job probably looking
at around 2000 jobs
2,000 jobs gone yeah Sydney was
devastated American town and just
destroyed it
Tim O'Connell runs the town's lumberyard
before the merger business was great we
were just buried you know with with
business now his customer base has
collapsed how many new homes have been
built since Cabela's and Bass Pro merged
in the city limits here there's before
Paul singer's hedge fund put Cabela's in
its sights Sydney was experiencing a
building boom we're gonna build a new
housing subdivision to meet housing
needs all these great things are
happening and instead we are working our
tails off to try to figure out a way to
survive for the people of Sydney it's
been a disaster those who want to leave
Sydney can't go housing values have
collapsed tethering them there for those
who want to stay it's almost impossible
to find a job how long does it take you
to find a new job
and as good as your old job as Sydney
collapsed Wall Street cashed in Paul
singer's hedge fund sold out before the
merger was even complete the fund made
nearly a hundred million dollars little
the Bronco small town
I hope all singers is proud of what he
did if money is that big of a God - it
was pretty sick human being wise we were
doing that story were warned repeatedly
by people around Washington
don't criticize Paul singer that's not a
good idea and as that package played I
got the following text from a very
well-known person in Washington holy
smokes I can't believe you're doing this
I'm afraid of Paul singer we'll see what
happens meanwhile Ben Sasse and this may
point to the point the texture was
making Ben Sasse is the US Senator
represents the state of Nebraska Sidney
of course isn't that large but you might
think the death of a town in his state
would be of concern to Ben Sasse again
u.s. senator from Nebraska but so far
doesn't seem like he's ever commented on
what's happened to Sidney we looked hard
then we called Sasa's office to see if
they could point to a time where he
commented on the destruction of Sidney
or simply supply a statement to us about
what happened there but Ben sasses
office didn't even respond to our
producers huh that's odd but then here's
one possible explanation for that
during his Senate run Ben Sasse received
the largest possible donation from Paul
singer